[Musique]
montgaillard vous traversez les rues en
dehors des passages cloutés
vous allez voir ce que cela vous coûte
inobservation des règlements d'ordre
public entorse aux arrêtés préfectoraux
contraventions et vous voilà bon % à 6
enfants damman vous prenez l'autobus en
marche ou tarifs cela fait 12 cents
fondamente vous en descendez dans le
même style
ces sportifs mais aussi coûteux 12 100
francs
cela m'est cher la section 2 de plus
vous pouvez être amour humaine éterniser
pas vos sentiments sur le socle des
statuts dégradation de monuments publics
12 à 60 mille francs d'amendé
vous avez joué 20 francs à la belote la
loi mais que les haricots 12 à 720 mille
francs d'amendé
surtout n'oubliez pas de fermer la porte
du petit endroit outrage à la pudeur
vous risquez une petite amende de 24
mille fois plus grave encore si vous
arborez un ruban de la sainte farce aux
îles légal de décoration cinquante mille
à un million loi pousse le scrupule
jusqu'à vous interdire de jouer aux
courses pour un ami elle appelle cela
pudiquement favoriser un pari 120000 à
12 cents mille francs
de sorte que votre journée pourra vous
coûter dans les 3 millions mais l'oeil
des règles de la loi a souvent une lueur
de pitié et les agents sont de braves
gens
[Musique]